now I have done a lot of videos on the
ketogenic diet but I wanted to include a
new video for beginners with all the
updates but I want to make it really
really simple so let's just start with
the basics what is a ketone a ketone is
not a fad it's not a carbohydrate it's
not a protein it's kind of a combination
or it has characteristics of both a fat
and a carbohydrate but it's not either
it comes from fat but a ketone is an
alternative fuel source and the way that
you get ketones is you simply lower your
carbohydrates in your diet or you reduce
the frequency of eating and this is why
we recommend a low carb diet with in a
minute fasting and that way you can
maximize your ability to make ketones
ketones have many advantages versus
regular glucose fuel number one and it
will increase your oxygen in your body
number two it increases your energy
number 3 it supports the brain in fact
your brain prefers ketones over glucose
same thing with the heart if your heart
is damaged or your brain is damaged
ketones are the answer and they can
bypass the mechanical damage pathways
and feed the tissues directly most of
the body tissues can run in ketones but
some parts need glucose and this is the
confusion that people have they think
they need to consume glucose to get
glucose no there's something called
gluconeogenesis ok
glucose neo New Genesis the creation of
your body can make glucose if it needs
it from fat ketones proteins you don't
need to consume carbohydrates to get
glucose now it does take time to turn
the fat into ketones it's going to take
between 3 to 5 days it all depends on
how damaged insulin is in your body how
damaged your pancreas is if you are a
pre-diabetic if you are a diabetic if
you have insulin or is
instance it's gonna take longer and
longer to adapt but by lowering the
carbs and going in in a minute fasting
you'll get there a lot faster that
explains how to get in ketosis you lower
the carb and you lower the frequency of
eating now why would you want to do
ketosis what what is the big benefit of
doing that well you're gonna lower
insulin and most people have high
insulin rarely does your doctor ever
test you for insulin they'll test you
for glucose but not insulin if they did
they probably would find higher levels
of insulin the tests that you would want
to do is called Homa
- ir and that will pick this up too much
insulin causes insulin resistance
insulin resistance is behind
pre-diabetes insulin resistance is
behind metabolic syndrome high blood
pressure a fat in the gut area right
through here and pre-diabetes leads to
diabetes so in reality diabetes stems
from high levels of insulin at certain
point and so keto and in amana fasting
will lower insulin and that is the big
benefit of doing this there's a lot of
other benefits too you can reduce fat
and your liver you can improve your
cognitive performance you can improve
your mood you can help decrease blood
pressure decrease inflammation improve
your energy and decrease your a belly
fat but the real big benefit that allows
you to do this eating plan is your
hunger goes away okay without being
hungry all the time it makes it really
easy to do long-term as a healthy
lifestyle and there's even an additional
benefit if you're doing intermittent
fasting that's a toff adji basically
what this is it's a recycling of garbage
in your tissue so all the damaged
protein the protein that your body
doesn't need it's clogging everything up
guess what your body will recycle that
and turn that into new amino acids
that's one of the big things about etapa
G to do this you have to fast at
least for 18 hours so the combination of
Quito and if' work very very nicely
together because if you just do Quito
without in a minute fasting and your
metabolism is slow you may not achieve
your weight loss goal or your other
goals because it would take a very very
long time and sometimes it's not going
to work why because the frequency of
eating in general will trigger insulin
so the frequency of eating is actually
very very important in relationship to
you lowering insulin all right then you
have this concept of a healthy keto plan
versus dirty keto of course we recommend
the healthy keto and this basically is
higher quality ingredients grass-fed Wow
caught pasture-raised versus
conventional type foods right here with
healthy keto you're focused on
nutrient-dense foods with dirty Kido
you're really just focused on keeping
your carbs low when you do healthy keto
you end up looking a lot better than
doing their dirty keto
alright the rule of thumb is don't eat
unless you have hunger okay unless you
have the sensation of being hungry when
you're doing the healthy version of keto
and you're doing enough leafy greens and
vegetables okay and you're doing enough
healthy fats and you're improving
insulin resistance you're not only going
to be full but you're going to be
satisfied now if you look at the pie
chart here we have about 5 percent carbs
of your total calories and then 5
percent vegetables which by the way
actually adds up to a lot because if you
look at the carbohydrates and vegetables
you - the fiber giving the net carb it
doesn't come out to a lot of calories so
if we look at the total carbs which
would include like berries hummus nuts
and seeds there's a little bit of carbs
in those and you combine the vegetables
that's like 10% then we have 20% protein
and then we have 70% fat now the fat
looks like a lot but realize fat is
basically double the calories of other
macronutrients but if we actually look
at an actual
with your food on the plate if you just
look at it like this to keep it really
simple have to play it vegetables okay a
coordinate would be protein and quarter
be fat but because protein is fat
usually come together that's going to be
pretty much half your plate that's what
it should look like the benefit of the
vegetables are the vitamin C and
minerals other nutrients and
phytonutrients
okay I'm going through this really fast
but I'm just giving you a summary in the
next few videos which I'm gonna put a
link down below I'm gonna talk more
about exactly what to eat when you're
eating but I wanted to give you the
simple overview of all the most
important things so now let's just put
it all together ideally when you wake up
in the morning if you keep your carbs
low you're not going to be hungry so you
want to skip breakfast and push it
forward to the point where your
breakfast now becomes your lunch so
don't eat in the morning you can do
coffee or tea so ideally your first meal
would be at lunch right here and then
your second meal would be a dinner so
you're doing two meals a day if you keep
this within a six-hour window that will
give you an 18 hour fast now what's
really magical about 18 hours as that's
when the etapa G starts you start
getting some really cool benefits the
way that you're gonna avoid snacking
between the meals is you're gonna add a
little more fat with this meal and this
meal to be able to go longer okay and
then as you start doing it and becoming
more adapted you can kind of cut back on
some of the fat because you're gonna be
burning your own fat and your own fat is
the healthiest fat that you can burn but
the key is this 18 hour fast right here
if you have to snack but within your
eating window fine if you need to do
that but we don't want to snack after
the dinner all the way to the next first
meal you can drink fluids you want to
take electrolytes and B vitamins for
sure and sea salt that's a necessity but
we recommend you you don't eat anything
become foods that are really good to
focus on would be pasture-raised eggs
okay Organic it's all possible shellfish
fish sardines meats organic cheese now a
lot of people don't do well in cheese
cheese has a lot of hormones it's not
good for people with prostate issues is
not good with people that have allergies
so some people do not do well in cheese
personally I do a small amount of cheese
and if I'm going to consume cheese it
has to be grass-fed organic I usually
get European cheese and I don't have a
tremendous amount but you can overdo it
with cheese olives that's a must
avocados lots of vegetables 7 to 10 cups
very beneficial nuts for some people
they don't do well on that especially if
they're prone to kidney stones you have
to be careful with almonds ok as well as
spinach so I'd avoid those if you're
prone to kidney stones also seeds like
sunflower seeds perfect on a ketogenic
plan alright here you have it the basic
ketogenic plan for beginners so if you
want more knowledge on how to create a
healthy body subscribe now and get daily
notifications